As we go to our next game,
#OscarsSoWhite.
As you probably heard,
uh, no actors of color
were nominated
at the Academy Awards this year.
So all the nominees just look
like a pristine snowcap.
Uh, despite amazing performances
in movies like Creed
and Straight Outta Compton--
I was really surprised,
especially by that. So, the
ceremony's gonna look more white
than, like, a chardonnay line
at a Coldplay concert, uh...
Luckily, the hashtag,
#OscarsSoWhite,
has been really hilarious
all week, like this tweet.
"#OscarsSoWhite that the bear
in Revenant would have snagged
a nomination if she were polar."
-That's good. That's good.
-Well done, Marlon James.
So we thought we'd get in
on the action.
Comedians, please give me
as many #OscarsSoWhite tweets
as you possibly can
in 60 seconds. And begin.
-Adam Savage. -They won't let
their daughter date the Tonys.
Points. Ron Funches.
#OscarsSoWhite they're giving
a lifetime achievement award
to the movie Powder.
Points. Adam.
The after-party's
at Cracker Barrel.
Points. Ron Funches.
Actually,
I heard the after-party
was at Boston Market.
Points. Ron Funches.
I heard they're attempting
to adopt Chris Rock.
Points. Rich Eisen.
It's a Matthew McConaughey
Joint.
Points. Adam Savage.
Music by Macklemore
and Mumford & Sons.
Points. Rich Eisen.
A brunette counts as diversity.
Points. Rich Eisen again.
Spike Lee will be played
by Channing Tatum.
All right, points.
Perfect.